in honor of pinhead's release in dead by
daylight in the legendary doug bradley's
birthday my buddy david and i are
looking over every hellraiser movie to
give our thoughts on what the next entry
in the series should look like be sure
to check out his channel for the other
videos for hellraiser week last time on
hellraiser
[Applause]
we reviewed the only good movies in the
hellraiser series
some classic british
ambiguously north american horror all
about desire and seduction and how
people's deepest urges can sometimes
lead us astray
now it's time to talk about the shitty
sequels
[Music]
it's actually shocking how many sequels
are in this series
what's even more interesting
is that they actually come in pairs the
two good ones and then all the sequels
fall into some kind of category we've
decided to list the franchise in four
handy chapters from here on out and each
chapter will be split up on each channel
hop back and forth this week to see each
one hellraiser three and four there was
an attempt bring that to me boy how
riser 3 and 4 were earnest attempts at a
proper follow-up and clive barker was
still involved behind the scenes along
with a few other producers of the
original two movies after the studio
behind the original films closed the
riots were bought by real-life creepy
sex demons the weinsteins these two were
the first to be released by dimension
films instead of new world pictures it's
interesting to watch these two because
there are legitimately interesting ideas
and story threads being used while a few
studio interference knives are poked
through the box from time to time
clyde barker's original idea for
hellraiser 3 was meant to follow up on
julia's character the crazy murder lady
from the first two movies but she said
no because
i don't know so then clive barker and
his gang threw around like a bazillion
weird creative off the walls bonkers
ideas and
the weinstein rejected them all for
being too expensive so then they made
the movie that they made
because none of the original characters
from the first two movies return it's
time for our first recurring trope of
these shitty hellraiser sequels a random
detective and or journalist
investigating the stuff that we already
know about from the previous movies
yay
this time it's that girl from star trek
deep space nine plays a wannabe cable
news anchor woman as opposed to that guy
from star trek deep space nine in the
first one and apparently that means that
she she's also like a
investigative journalist in addition to
being a cable news woman but whatever in
hellraiser 3 the story goes that some
guy who owns a rave fine dining
restaurant in the warehouse district of
new york filmed in north carolina which
also has a sex nasium in the back room
that he beds random women in he gets
statues some weird [__] from an
antique dealer
and it's actually what's left of
pinprick the infallible the statue
temporarily reanimates when it comes in
contact with blood much like the sex
mattress or the floorboard heart from
the previous films hey did you know that
the original novella it wasn't blood
that frank left behind on the
floorboards but
yeah i think he said that in the other
script yeah
i i
i just like to mention it
ah
okay
so then pinhead's silly face sticks out
of the statue and tells the bar owner to
keep feeding him murder so he can come
back meanwhile a cable news lady that's
our main character investigates the
events of the last movies slash a trail
of crimes while getting weird dreams
about the human half of pinhead elliot
we discover that pinhead's evil side was
indeed stripped from nice guy elliott in
the previous movie but now he worries
that his dark side will continue to
wreak havoc until they stop him so he
enlists a cable news reporter and her
goth semi-girlfriend to defeat evil evil
pinhead grows his power and tries to
replace his old cenobytes with new 90s
designs like
camera head
cd face
cigarette neck
the other nightmare on elm street
rejects
there was some weird sacrilegious
imagery which tried to be like edgy but
was just kind of lame cool gore though
so all this one wasn't
that
bad compared to what will come later
it's still just kind of boring
the mystery isn't interesting because if
you've watched the previous films in the
series you already know it
and the main characters are likable but
they don't have any flaws or arcs
pinhead thankfully acts like
pinhead believe me the later films will
screw that up and he does have a couple
of cool lines here and there
jesus christ
not quite
so it ends with reporter girl number one
battling pinhead with elliot elliot
sacrifices himself by merging with
pinhead once again to reign him in from
complete wanton destruction and they go
back to their killing as a fun weekend
activity not a full-time job vibe
and cable news lady gentee attacks
reporter girl number one buries the
puzzle box and some concrete at the
foundation of a building we end with a
teaser for the sequel where the whole
building is an evil puzzle murder box so
what you're saying is that capitalism
was the whole evil murder puzzle box the
whole time
get it because
building in new york
manhattan
wall street
banking money capitalism
okay i'll go back to my corner much like
these character designs you're trying
too hard now get back to buying gamestop
stock
hellraiser 3 is honestly not too bad its
ideas were a bit muddled but i
appreciate that it didn't just throw
away the previous films entirely and
followed up on them with some main beats
from them
it's just got this problem of not
knowing exactly where to go from here
this movie feels like an awkward middle
chapter because all they could achieve
is bringing back pinhead because he was
a fan favorite
i guess their plan was just to see where
they could go from there
so where did they go from there
to
spam
[Music]
that's right hellraiser did their jason
x in number four
that's making friday the 13th look
reputable by comparison
which is
weird because of all the sequels this is
actually
one of the better ones
and by better i mean
the most creative and unique one
it actually tries to do the themes of
the first two films in a new and
interesting way it also has a giant
puzzle box in space that blows up at the
end and kills pinhead and all his
friends who once again are
interdimensional bdsm sex demons
it's
it's a lot the story of this film spans
like 400 years and tells the story of
the original man who built the puzzle
box and the curse it brings on all of
his descendants from that point onward
including his great great great great
shut up grandson who built that silly
ass skyscraper at the end of the last
one and then the next guy after that a
few centuries down line who built a
satellite to study the cube because he
knew it would be too dangerous to look
over it on earth
so there might have been a really
interesting film in here at some point
the original director kevin yeager
delivered a cut of the film to miramax
that ran 110 minutes they weren't happy
with it they thought it was too slow
they thought certain character dynamics
didn't work so then a bunch of stuff was
cut a bunch of stuff was re-edited and
another director joe chappelle was
brought in to reshoot even more stuff so
the finished film runs just 85 minutes
now there is a more complete cut out
there on youtube based upon lost footage
and like runescape video game animatics
based on the original script so if
you're curious about that check it out
because this version is just boring so
much was changed in post-production that
original director jaeger demanded his
name be taken off the production fun
fact this was one of the final uses of
the infamous alan smithy credit some of
the new cenobyte designs are actually
halfway decent like the twins or this
skull cap effect
and this movie is like trying to do
something it gave a [__] what i found
really interesting was the addition of
the demon angelica hellraiser 4
establishes that the puzzle box predates
the cenobites or at least the way we see
them the box enslaves the a demon called
angelica who represents a different idea
of hell and she's present throughout the
story because of that now she's more
about temptation and drawn out seduction
versus the chains and hooks so you know
more cheating on your wife at the bar
with another girl
than bdsm
blood piercing sex clubs and the
relationship between pinhead and
angelica could have been really
interesting to explore but they didn't
give it enough time to cook and in the
original cut they were a lot more
confrontational versus in the reshoots
when they re-edited it remade it to be a
bit more sexual tensiony you know
because woman man
sexual tension automatic blah blah blah
it's a non-linear movie that jumps
across 400 years so when few characters
carry over and you deal with more of a
family line than one person you need to
make sure that the themes hit in the
characters count but the ending for all
of its
giant satellite puzzle box explosions is
just kind of lame
one thing you can praise this film for
is the sense of finality it had the
nards to just say this is the final
story of pinhead and show a definitive
death for the character
however
that death is in like 200 years in space
so he still got a lot of trouble to
cause until then
a lot of judgey
disinteresting
poorly thought out
badly shot
poorly rendered
trouble so
the next video in this series which will
be on the other channel link in the
description will deal with my least
favorite films in the entire series
which have seriously jeopardized my
friendship with xavier
i still haven't forgiven him for
exposing my eyeballs to these films
these two in particular and one
specifically we'll see you next time
looking forward to it
[Music]
you